Hey I just want to start by saying I did
not plan on my 666 video being about iOS
total coincidence I promise hey what is
up guys I'm kitty HD here and this week
Apple unveiled its newest version of its
mobile OS for iPhones and iPads and
that's iOS 8 I was tempted to do an
updated version of where iOS 7 features
came from with where iOS 8 features came
from but that would actually have been a
pretty boring video because they all
really came from some previous version
of Android not that's a bad thing I mean
we already know Google and Apple take
features from each other all the time
if that just would've been a boring
video so even though you could easily go
to Apple's website and just read down
the list of new features a lot of people
have asked me for my thoughts on iOS 8's
new features so if I'd any further ado
yeah these are my impressions of iOS 8
now first of all iOS 8 is not a big
major overhaul from iOS 7 in fact it's
visually basically identical it's really
more of a collection of new features and
nifty tricks that make it a new
operating system for Apple and honestly
if I was a full-time iOS user I would be
very happy with a lot of these so the
biggest collection of new features is
under the umbrella called continuity and
that is for people who also have a Mac
so it's for people who have an iPhone
and a Mac and your Mac will detect if
your iPhone is nearby and basically
start syncing information between them
presumably over Bluetooth so you can
start typing an iMessage on your phone
and then realize oh I actually want to
write an essay in this iMessage so you
can swap over to your Mac and continue
writing that iMessage pick up right
where you left off and because of
continuity and this Bluetooth sync it
knows where you left off and you can
pick up the exact spot if your Mac sees
that your iPhone is nearby it will put a
one click hotspot up in your system tray
although it doesn't really seem clear
what it's doing it seems like if you
just click it oh now we're connected but
you're using your phone now as a hotspot
it's really nifty if you're on the train
or something and you have your laptop in
your lap and your phone in your pocket
you can just click on it and you're
connected to the Internet but I feel
like a lot of people are gonna
accidentally activate this and not
really know what they're doing
we'll see you also have the ability to
airdrop between iOS devices and Macs
which a lot of people have been waiting
for and you now have SMS sink on
iMessage between your computers and your
iPhone which is extremely you
so this is something I really wish
hangouts would get on hangouts for
Android and iOS and the web could be so
much more robust if they adopted all
these SMS sync features but they don't
so that's a huge area where iMessage
gets a thumbs up aside from that there
are a couple of other system level
tweaks that like I said will look very
familiar to Android users you have
interactive notifications now so if you
get a new notification you can swipe
down on it to like a Facebook message or
reply to an iMessage or any number of
things that you can do once you've
expanded the notification and you never
have to leave the app you're in so
that's nifty you have widgets in the
notification panel now that also
third-party apps can plug into so now
you have a fully customizable
notification panel with all sorts of
widgets of your choice and glanceable
information that is really nifty
spotlight search has gotten way more
powerful before you're only really
searching what's on your phone but now
just like Google now if you search in
spotlight you can get maps things you
can get iTunes results you can get
points of interest Google results all
kinds of things like that so spotlight
also more nifty and iOS 8 now has some
awesome new keyboard improvements one
being the new first-party keyboard which
has better autocorrect and better next
word prediction exactly like SwiftKey
does on Android and number 2 you know
how support for third-party keyboards
and iOS very nifty messages also now has
audio and video chat snapchat style so
you can just swipe up from the
microphone in the text box field and
it'll give you the ability to just
record a quick audio message and send it
not sure how many people are going to
use this because usually when I'm
texting it's because I want to avoid
talking on the phone or using audio but
it's there and now also there's two
microphones one in the text box field
for swiping and another in the keyboard
itself for speech to text recognition so
we'll see how confusing that gets but
it's a new feature and it's there also
there is iCloud Drive which works
exactly like Google Drive no real need
to explain that and a new healthkit
system which basically uses a bunch of
sensors to keep track of your health
information although it seems like they
could use an extra bit of hardware
perhaps something wearable to really tie
into that system
we'll see where they go with that and
there's family sharing you know the new
Photos app with a bunch more photo
editing features there's the new
programming languages WWDC they
introduced a new programming language
called Swift which is a huge deal for
developer
and we'll see how this impacts iOS apps
moving forward I'm sure a lot of people
are going to find this very important
but overall you know a bunch of
significant features and a nice
collection of new things thrown into iOS
that like I said will seem familiar to
people who have used Android but I'm
sure are very welcome to full-time iOS
users I like how much more open and
customizable it seems you know I mean I
know it's baby steps but it seems like
they're removing bricks from the top of
the wall in the walled garden
how's that for visual seriously it's a
different attitude it's like you know
the third-party keyboard thing I would
have never expected to see that on iOS 3
years ago you know just to lock down
obviously Android is open source so you
can use whatever keyboard you want but I
feel like Apple was looser you know they
crack more jokes they had some more open
features and they just talked about
things in a different way and I feel
like this is the beginning of them
seeing a lighter maybe I'm just being
optimistic but I felt like I was happy
with their attitude at WWDC not that
they would care what I think of their
attitude but I feel like it's step in
the right direction and I like the open
sense of what I'm feeling so I'm feeling
the vibe I really like it and I'm diggin
the direction that Apple is headed yes
they will take jabs at Android and then
adopt its features and the same breath
but it's all part of the game and maybe
we'll see some iOS 9 features at Google
i/o in a few months either way thanks
for watching this video on my quick
thoughts on iOS 8 obviously you could
just read the stuff yourself if you
really want to get into the nitty-gritty
of the details but let me know what you
guys think are you excited for iOS 8 are
you excited to put it on your iPad or
your iPhone I'm just going to wait for
the full version to be released instead
of just messing with the beta but I'm
actually personally more excited for a
Mac os10 or just OS 10 Yosemite which is
the new desktop operating system very
pumped for that but either way like I
said thanks for watching let me know
what you guys think I don't talk to you
guys the next one base
you